ich habe zwei freunde darum gebeten
personen allein anhand ihres outfits zu
erhalten was dabei rumgekommen ist
erfahrt ihr in dieser zweiten folge von
test hallo hallo norman halle
hey du bist heute versuchen personen
alleine anhand ihres auftretens und
eines kleinen gespräch ist die richtigen
outfits zuzuordnen aber ich hasse und
sehr schwer
ich würde nicht sagen dass das ist auf
jeden fall schaffen kann aber ist und
gebe mir schon gespannt was denkst du
wie viele der outfits du richtig
zuordnen kannst alle man muss doch ok
hab ich einfach anfangen ja ich gehe
daher einfach mal ein bisschen dran ich
hoffe dass in ordnung
es ist nur 6 pm hose geht ja fast heute
abgezogen werken das ist also ein
bisschen flex aber loki ich könnte mir
auch vorstellen dass das oberteil
irgendwie secondhand ist oder so von den
eltern oder so ein paar fans sie sagt
alles relativ helle töne ein bisschen
crazy us dann würde ich schätzen dass es
auf jeden fall eine person ist die
klamotten eher eng anliegend mag es ist
nicht deine beste bist du dir sicher
und das gefällt mir sehr gut dieses
outfit und das hier verwirrt mich sehr
also eine silberne jacke würde ich jetzt
zum ersten blick so niemanden zu ordnen
wie war der name unter studiert
modedesign ja ok ok modedesign also auf
jeden fall fashion interessiert das
bringt mich trotzdem nicht so wirklich
weiter und jetzt
[Musik]
ich sage einfach dafür
ich glaube ich würde dir sogar schon so
rein optisch einfach so dass ich denke
dass es sehr gut stehen würde und das
erste zu teilen aber das ist noch nicht
mehr nun endgültige antwort ich mal ganz
kurz checken oder du könntest auch weil
du gerade wurde design student ist so
auf ganz fleißigen und eine silva jacke
tragen das kind auch sein aber das ist
einen goldenen ohrring und deshalb
glaube ich nicht dass du selber
ich glaube ich geb dir das erste auto
kommt das würde ich dir zu teilen wieder
so gar keine reaktion ich es gerade
jetzt gut oder schlecht ein wie heißt du
ja ok hallo wie geht es dir auch gut was
machst du so ich studiere medien design
mediendesign auch design vision der
store in köln und 1
das land hätte mehrere gewinner der
rückseite danke ich weiß eigentlich ist
das jetzt geholfen hat vielleicht das so
gerne t shirts trägt sich zeigt manager
ist aber gerne mag supermann
[Gelächter]
ich hasse meinen füßen dritter jeden tag
laufen schwer sehr schwer
also ich glaube dass black würde ich
ausschließen erstmals nicht irgendwie
hab ich da schon so eine idee wer das
sein könnte das glaube ich auch nicht
weil ich weiss nicht mediendesigner ich
habe mir das hier noch gar nicht richtig
angeschaut
nike auch schwer ich glaube das sind die
richtig richtig clean aus an der person
der das gehört ich glaube das ist ein
richtig richtig gut organisiert das auto
etwas dann auch nur so die personen
tragen kann wie das sonst trägt aber ich
würde die trotzdem glaube ich keine
silberne jacke zu teilen mit dem also
das ist auch so dass ich mir dass wir
haben das schon ausgeschlossen
das habe ich jetzt ausgeschlossen dass
eigentlich auch dann bleibt eigentlich
mal das übrig aber ich weiß was ich kann
ich mir eigentlich so vorstellen will
aber ich geb dir erstmal das ist
vielleicht würde ich am ende noch mal
aber erst dann will ich dir das zu
teilen das ist ja okay danke schön
wie heißt du hast wissenschaften
studiert und hast das letzte mal geweint
letztes jahr
oktober man leute dieses jahr im oktober
gekauft und hat sehr viel gekostet
jetzt ist ja das könnte ich jetzt sagen
das hast du deswegen steht irgendein
komisch italienischer name drauf und
dann muss das meist teuer
bist du auf instagram bisher in
modemäßig unterwegs vielleicht die folge
sie sie erst da ist er schon zurück aber
selber selber nicht so ich habe ein bild
ok krass war seit sich zum beispiel
schon mal nicht eingeschätzt ich hätte
gedacht du wärst du four bg mitglied
eigentlich hätte ich das vielleicht
sogar zugeteilt ich dachte du könntest
auf jeden fall rocken aber auch wieder
gleich als zeuge wie gerade eben
goldener ring goldene brille silber
jacke
ganz kurz kommen auch noch irgendwas ist
auch eine goldene kette an also entweder
ist das der person egal
oder ich bin einfach schlecht ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich sehe dich in dem
outfit ist sehe ich in dem outfit und
ich bin ich in dem outfit aber irgendwie
ich weiß nicht du bist du ich glaube du
hast teams an das sind glaube ich dass
all blacks von dir
es kann ich ja auch gut vorstellen ich
gebe es wenn du dir gut stehen wo er
stimmt wird sie silber ja kann ja ich
glaube ich bleibe erstmal bei dem
schwarzen ich würde sagen du hast fleck
okay sagt das heißt du carsten wie geht
es dir
großartig hier noch bis zum 24
was machst du so außer dem beruf noch so
hast du das machst du gerne deine
freiheit ich gehe sehr gern zum sport ja
ich habe lange fußball gespielt selber
spielt auch immer noch regelmäßig immer
mal macht die musik
schlagzeug ewigkeiten gespielt neben
gesangsunterricht spielen bisschen
gitarre also musikrichtung viel und
ansonsten was man halt so finden kann in
köln mit freunden des fußballspiels hat
mir glaube ich tatsächlich bisschen
weitergeholfen alsono fortan jeden
fußballer das gerade sieht aber ich
finde fußballer haben einen fußball
style so weiß nicht ich finde bei
fußballern kann man das oft sehen also
am style von leuten kann man oft
erkennen ob die fußballspieler nicht zum
letzten mal deine schuhe gewaschen
die die gerade da stehen potenziell
kölner letzten generell auch geputzt
wird schon monate er sein bestimmt das
ist aber nicht die idee hier stehen
wahrscheinlich ja gute frage ich finde
es passt einfach optisch gut zu dir
würde ich dir das klassische outfit zu
ordnen glaube ich weiß das sind die
passenden schuhe dazu nur ja gut ich
wollte gerade noch so ein bisschen
versuchen rauszufinden ob die schnelle
antwort dass auch dass die richtige
schule sind okay dass ich bleibe bei dem
aber erstmal muss ich werde dir das zum
teil sicher
hallo wie heißt du das machst du so sehr
im endeffekt bleibt mir eben doch das
mit dem silbernen also das silberne
outfit
muss ja du hast das so genau nahm
also bis auf diese jacke sie kann ich
mir gut vorstellen aber diese jacke hat
wie ich so sehr dass auch mal schwer
unseres m
doch aber ich glaube ich könnte mir auch
gut stehen das ist ja trotzdem immer
noch so ein lobbyist kiesswetter eine
relativ schlichte hose und airforce dann
kann man auch so ein statement seiner
jacke setzen
ich könnte es mir auch bei dir
vorstellen aber ich habe trotzdem gerade
nicht so ein gutes gefühl
ja ich glaub nicht teil dir diese bei
jacke zu bevor wir das hier beenden und
auflösen ob das richtig ist möchte ich
noch einmal kurz durch gehen und gucken
ob ich auch zufrieden mit meinen
entscheidungen bin ich durchaus zu
behalten
ich bleibe auch dabei glaube ich kann
ich mir auch vorstellen
ja da bin ich mir relativ sicher
ja ja ja ja ich bleibe ich bleibe beim
ich bleibe meinen entscheidungen
hast du das wird sich schon falsch an
wie hier rein läuft wir sind hat sich
das falsch ja doch doch von den längen
her sieht sie mal passend aus eigentlich
du bist richtig
[Musik]
aber es steht ja auch würden das steht
ja auch geholt habe ich ja gesagt
halle weil fox aber nichts
3 natürlich richtig krass kreis hätte
ich also krass aber steht der decke
möglich war
patrick also wie anders das ist jetzt so
nadja alle gerade weißes t-shirt eine
schwarze hose jetzt diesen unterschied
zu sehen ist crazy style macht sehr viel
aus sollte das motto auf jeden fall mehr
sind wirklich bescheiden aber sind
vielen dank
danke dass sie bis jetzt zugeschaut habt
und falls die selbe bank hat in einer
folge dabei zu sein checkt einfach den
link in der beschreibung aus und standen
seid ihr vielleicht beim nächsten mal
hier in diesem raum mit uns